right okay
okay thank you all for returning this
afternoon the committee has considered
all the written evidence and the
representations made at the hearing the
committee has also considered carefully
the concerns raised by the interested
party relating to the potential for the
increased hours applied for in the
license application impacting on
antisocial behavior noise and
disturbance to residents living in the
vicinity of the premises part of the
high street in respect of the
Licensing's objectives of the prevention
of crime and disorder the prevention of
public nuisance and public safety
however no representations have been
made at the hearing by Essex Police
environmental health or local residents
in addition the police have agreed
conditions with the applicant that they
will consider to serve to promote these
Licensing's objectives the committee has
therefore resolved to grant the premises
license subject to standard conditions
and the conditions agreed by the police
and the applicants the committee reminds
all those present that the applicant
must adhere to all the conditions apply
to this license and that if there are
any problems in the future as a result
of the grant of this license a review of
the license can be requested at any time
this concludes the meeting and thank you
all for attending and afternoon